got Alicia's back I walked into the
bunker and she was just there like
nothing had happened
like maybe it was some kind of gift how
much does she know about what's happened
we're using her it was about the process
the recruits Prometheus the fact that
you killed his dead Lucia violin I'm
working on finding his mother but Ivan
what to do a train the two of you well
she doesn't stay in one spot for very
long but I'm working on finding her
it means I'm we need to work on a way of
getting you out of here yeah well we did
that remember Here I am right back on
the inside my John's Amin no more ready
this time I face this head-on like these
trumped-up charges it's an improvement
from musta Roger that
I'm gonna show Walker then he picked the
wrong soldier to school with we need to
have some kind of plan Lindiwe no a
lawyer I mean okay
hey youtubers it's Charlie so arrow
episode 10 footage let's break it down
just careful for spoilers if you're not
caught up there just like a few things
that we have to talk about there were
some big reveals at the end of episode 9
so here we go there is a new round of
the flash ring giveaway going on now -
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything during
the break so I'm just gonna assume that
you've seen episode 9 by now and you
know the twist that happens at the end
of that so just here we go okay so the
person they're talking about that's back
it's like a gift is a laurel they
haven't fully explained the twists that
brought her back but the showrunners
hinted that flashpoint might have a
little bit to do with that meaning that
it had a lot to do with that but we'll
explain that in a second the other stuff
they explained in this is that she
doesn't know anything about what's
happened with Prometheus or the new
recruits meaning she doesn't know
anything since she was killed in season
4 so that means that this is earth one
laurel she's not from another earth it's
not black siren it's not some evil
version of her pretending to be the
earth one Laurel so Oliver just saying
that he has to catch her up in bits and
pieces were easing her into it she
doesn't know anything about this Diggle
is also behind bars still saying hey I
have to own up for this I have to see it
through so the funny thing here when
they talk about needing a good lawyer
and Oliver says I think I know a guy
he's probably talking about Adrian chase
which is the new district attorney who's
part of a much bigger plot line that we
can talk about once they reveal it let's
just say that there's gonna be a lot of
district attorney stuff happening in the
back half of the season the next big
thing is Oliver tracking down the woman
that trained both him and Prometheus in
Russia in the flashbacks who we'll
probably see in the flashbacks
he says she moves around a lot she
doesn't stay in one place he's probably
talking about Talia al Ghul who's being
played by LexA Doig so we don't know a
whole lot about how they're gonna
characterize the arrowverse version of
Talia I think she's gonna be relatively
comic-book accurate but for the time
being she's gonna be more of a flashback
character but it sounds like one of
those situations where the flashback
character gets to show up in present-day
later when the storylines start to
converge because she's like a common
point between Oliver and Prometheus like
Prometheus learned all of the
of assassins moves that Oliver learned
from Thalia so the other thing is that
Susan Williams a lot of you have been
asking about the vodka bottles in her
room when Oliver went to see her those
are probably there because she's looking
for a really hot story on Oliver Queen
about his secret past not everybody
knows that he didn't spend all five
years on that island so she learned
about someone who knew him in Russia
that's probably where she got the vodka
from in the reason I think the camera
focused on it so much they really wanted
you to notice it like hey look at this
Russian vodka isn't that funny that that
shows up is just to remind you that
Susan Williams even though she's being
really nice to Oliver helping him
through this really tough time has her
own agenda so a lot of people were
wondering maybe she's in with prometheus
maybe she has something to do with the
twist no all I think it is is that she's
looking for a hot story that will
eventually bite Oliver in the ass so
she'll seem kind of like an [ __ ] even
though she cares about him she wants to
be a good reporter so she's not gonna
like sit on the story just because she
likes Oliver so that's gonna drive them
apart by the end of the season so you
have to have like a reason for new guest
actors to leave and go back to wherever
they came from so that would be a really
good reason if she pissed Oliver off by
publishing a big expose about how he was
in Russia and not stuck on the island
the whole time next big thing learning
more about Prometheus's backstory
there's been a lot of confusion since
the episode 9 just in Clayborne reveal
so they examined the ashes and they
belonged to Claybourne so the baby
picture just meant that prometheus was
his son Oliver killed his father just
like Princess Bride
Prometheus now views Oliver as the
villain you killed my father
prepare to die so the big problem with
that though is that Prometheus his
father was really evil and if you've
read the comics or maybe you haven't
read the comics Prometheus was also the
son of two criminals that were killed by
the Justice League so he vowed revenge
so just like comic book Prometheus TV
show Prometheus wants to kill Oliver and
make him suffer for losing the father
that he probably had really complicated
feelings about because it didn't sound
like Justin Claybourne was that great of
a dad anyway so Oliver loved his father
who was kind of shady for a great
portion of his life
Prometheus loved his
so in that way he's kind of like a dark
version of Oliver like the darkest
timeline version of Oliver so I don't
think there's gonna be a big twist
beyond that but they do say that they're
trying to track down his mother
Prometheus's mother so if there's gonna
be some big twist then that would be it
like who is his mother we know who his
father is it's just in Claybourne but
for those of you wondering or expecting
some grand twist
you know maybe prometheus is tied to
somebody that we already know his mother
would be the back door to that so you
guys can let me know who do you think
Prometheus's mother is is it somebody
we've never met before like it'll be a
brand new person on the show or is it
somebody that we've heard about how much
would you riot if it was Oliver's mother
like she secretly had Thea with Malcolm
Merlyn so you know that she already
cheated on all of her father with Merlin
so what if she also had a relationship
with someone else that would just make
everybody so pissed off so whoever
Prometheus's mother is what I'm
expecting is is that it's someone we've
never seen before next we got to talk
all about Black Canary being back so I
don't think that she's gonna be a series
regular so whatever they do with her
even if she's a big part of the back
half of the season I think that she'll
just come back on a recurring basis
she's supposed to show up on legends of
tomorrow sometime this season and who
knows if she's going to be another one
of those husks that we saw from the
flash the dr. alchemy husks so the flash
people would like to tie this to the
flash have said that there will be at
least one more husk that team flash will
go up against on that TV show so really
the only thing a husk would be good for
for laurels character for Black Canary
would be to turn her into a metahuman
like maybe flashpoint Black Canary
wasn't metahuman
so if during that episode nine battle
when dr. alchemy was slowly activating
all of the remaining metas using that
amplifier dish if Laurel got tagged that
could be a way for her to get her canary
cry
from flashpoint they will become the
servants you guys can let me know if you
think they'll go that direction or if
it'll just be regular Laurel just like
we had before and that's the only
difference is that she's just not dead
anymore but congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner lightning Goku
you win a flash ring please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
is a new round that started now in this
video
swell announce a winner the next time I
post a DC video next I'll be posting
some more Rick and Morty in my Star Wars
rogue one Easter Egg so make sure you go
see the movie when you get the chance
well you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to watch the flash
trailer for the next episode and you can
click here from my non-spoilery rogue
one review thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight